[Music]  this past weekend was part one of the  Coachella Music Festival and the big  highlight is very strange Snoop Dogg and  dr. Dre performed with a 3d hologram of  Tupac Shakur it was it was it was odd  check it out  [Applause]  yeah it was now I bring us up for a  reason I'm irritated okay I am I'm very  irritated by this because we have had  rapper hologram technology on this show  for quite a while okay and we didn't get  any notice for it nobody everyone's  talking about this today yeah but our  rapper hologram technology has been  ignored in fact for the past few months  we've had a famous rapper hologram  actually working backstage at the show  check it out copies cold feed boy  so you check you out here and I'm in  there  [Music]  what is he yelling at a fire no and how  does that constitute working on the show  Oh No somebody's got to get out there  and yell at that hydrant that's one of  our most prized internships